[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
texte venait pas de moi que je venais la
donne et la rotax max alors je vous
donne le juge je dis venez latex il ya
des mares et je me crois que je crois
que vous avez pris le l'ancien single
qu'on avait ya cinq ans vous voulez pas
payer
allez on y va texte au cateau sur
comment ça se passe alors la finale d
amour on rappelle donc vous poser des
questions à jean michel c'est ça et lui
doit répondre sur jean-michel alors lui
dois me dire vous avez répété oui je
peux nous expliquer ce que vous
expliquez vous que vous devez donc
répondre par oui ou non de manière
intelligible un dé qui vous a dit oui ou
non retirer vous donner votre réponse ou
à 45 secondes pour gagner une semaine
avec xavier demaison à new york un exact
alors attention ils ont une minute c'est
ça 45 secondes barbacki attention jean
michel thierry connait-il votre mot
préféré oui non top je vois la femme qui
rapportent d'autres fantasmes
oui la femme qui représente votre
fantasme
oui oui celle où c'est le loup s'il joue
vite dit oui ça défile le métier qu'ils
voulaient faire petit pilote de char oui
non attention on s'arrête
vous devez attendre qu'il ait dit oui ou
non encore attention parce que la
prochaine fois c'est dehors
mais attention à un moment donné nous il
ya quand même un cadeau à la clé elle
faisait partie jean miche jolis textes
carrément le débile profond
jean michel thierry connait-il top la
couleur qu'il est est plus pour la
lingerie non rouge
son signe astrologique oui scorpion son
loisir préféré
oui drague et toc
on s'arrête il reste combien de temps il
nous reste 12 secondes vous avez quatre
bonnes réponses attention encore deux et
vous partez à new york on est reparti
attention jean-michel tiers des icônes
et hilltop la couleur de soldes ce clip
aujourd'hui nom le prénom de votre
première petite amie
non votre chanson préférée oui les
sardines top on va s'arrêter c'est une
catastrophe
et si vous dites mais pas le soir là
c'est pas gagné mais vous gagnez un week
end
[Applaudissements]
merci je sais pas pourquoi ça je sens
qu'on va le coupé maison parce que
fallait dire oui des fois pour qu'il
dise mes trucs ce soit oui oui vous
n'avez pas vu la finale qui a été joué
dans n'y a pas d'âge avec brasseur et
carmen mans